oh I call Gary Joe you are here right by
the table and I'm Bob Mendelsohn
okay thank you very much it's a it's a
real honor to be here and it's a
pleasure to be invited to continue the
conversation on the stern review it's
turned into a little bit of a full
employment act for economists oh no a
little bit about climate and it's likely
to continue that way for quite a while
I've been asked to think a little bit
about the stabilization think about the
mitigation side of the review and as I
do I want to start by identifying
Richard toll as a collaborator and
co-author and an awful lot of what I've
put together over the last couple of
three or four months in response to the
stern review and and I think that
Richard I would both say that we've
learned an enormous amount about what we
think about this problem by trying to
work through what we saw in the stern
review my tasks then is to consider the
mitigation side I'd like to do it in
light of the most recent science in
light of what can and cannot be gleaned
from the review in terms of net benefits
cast and what might best serve
decision-makers who face the question of
what to do over the near term that's
what Sir Nicholas was just focusing our
attention on and what I'm going to try
to suggest is that it might be good to
get them out of the burden of solving
the climate problem that's just not
going to happen we're not going to set
policy in 2007 for the entire century or
220 for 2500 or or whatever whatever
what we need to do is acknowledge the
problem design something in the near
term that minimizes expected adjustment
costs as the science evolves and work in
creating a structure within which that
science can be taken on board without
political manipulation to reiterate some
of the important points that I'm sure
you've heard if you've been here all day
and you're starting to get a headache
from thinking about it the recent
literature suggests that climate change
is changing more rapidly
either win thought five years ago Rachel
Warren did a wonderful supporting
document to emphasize that and what they
conclude in the science that they used
is entirely consistent with fourth
assessment report Working Group one
document that was agreed to two weeks
ago in Paris it continues to notice that
impacts are likely to become more severe
they're likely to have already been
observed and attributed to human
activity and the impacts are likely to
be felt sooner than thought say five
years ago I think though one of the most
important conclusions in representations
of the sciences in blue there it's Yale
after all that no temperature target can
be guaranteed by any practicable
concentration limit what you can do is
think about the range of uncertainty
that a particular concentration
stabilization target could generate you
can think about the risks it could
diminish but you cannot assume and work
off of a one-to-one association between
temperature and concentration that makes
the problem risk management problem and
something that can help us frame the
discussion of stabilization now some are
going to argue with the numbers on that
on the mitigation side as well as just
as they did on the benefits side I think
that focusing on the numbers runs the
risk of missing the major points and to
me there are two if the question is what
should we be doing in terms of
mitigation particularly in the near term
one of them i think is to inform the
debate on what to do in the near term in
a way that's consistent with a long-term
evolution of the science and a long-term
acknowledgement of a considerable
problem and the second thing that
hearings like this and discussions
amongst academics can produce is some
idea of where our efforts to sort
through the uncertainties and the
controversies can produce the greatest
benefits economist being economist
we will argue with ourselves a lot the
point is where can we spend most of our
time in the arguments to be most
productive and a good friend of mine
Lester lave from Carnegie Mellon has a
factor of 2 rule for climate change and
the factor of 2 rule is that if it
doesn't make a difference of a factor of
2 it's inside the noise so you probably
should move on and look for something
else to worry about I want to spend just
a minute or two on the risk-based per
capita consumption metric for damages
that the stern review uses I think this
is a key inside a key application of
sound fundamental economic theory it's
provocative and its innovative from what
I understand you compute per capita
consumption runs using chris's Chris
hopes page model compute the discounted
utility for each one of those at 0.1
percent discounting compute expected
discounted utility across the full set
of runs given the probability weights
from the from the page model compute a
certainty equivalent that is a level of
consumption which if it grew at one
point three percent per year would
generate a level of utility equal to the
expected utility across all of that
complication on all of that future and
the damages are the difference between
doing that with and without climate
change and so you get results and you
get statements like it is equivalent to
a reduction of 5.3 percent of our capita
GDP now and forever does it mean that
tomorrow we're going to wake up and
we've lost five point three percent of
our per capita consumption it means it's
equivalent to that so it's as if
although these are just made up lines
they have no basis in anything in
reality but they do show some some range
of disagreement the certainty equivalent
sort of says where would I start at a
one point three percent increase to
generate a level of utility equal to the
discounted expected utility across all
of those futures so it's taking an
enormous amount of complication and
putting it down into one number some
will argue that the mitigation costs are
underestimated
the cost of course depend on design how
flexible they are how persistent how
predictable what you do with the revenue
I'm a little concerned that if the
damage estimates are so much higher than
have been put forward earlier why 550
parts per million is still the target
that you might want to talk about it was
justified earlier with smaller damages
is something to think about but more
fundamentally and the reason that I I
went through that description of the
certainty equivalence is that it's
difficult to compare the metrics of the
mitigation costs in the stern review
with the damage metrics the mitigation
metric is perceptive GDP the damage
metric is percentage of per capita
consumption reduced so we've never
really I've never been able to really
see in the review comparison of them
those numbers so Richard and I did our
own we set up a very very simple little
climate model with a couple of three
regions and some some assumptions about
climate sensitivity and rates of growth
and vulnerability and so on and so forth
and we calibrated it so that unregulated
we would get to about a thousand parts
per million is the maximum and we would
lose a per capita consumption equivalent
of five point three percent and then we
sort of held the concentrations to
particular stabilization targets and 550
parts per million is identified there it
shows a reduction in this damage from
five point three percent down to 2.2% it
satisfies Lester's rule it's greater
than a factor of two and so it's making
making a difference to get to 400 parts
per million you could get damages below
one percent but it's important to notice
that these aren't net damages these are
net savings these are growth savings so
there's no cost of mitigation subtracted
from from then it's just a reflection of
what the value would be of those
particular stabilizations so are there
anything else in there that sort of
would satisfy Lester's rule heard a lot
of discussion about the discount rate
and our little experiment if we lower
the discount rate actually from
0.1% is 0.01 percent the damages go from
five point three percent to five point
four percent so we've picked these 0.1%
pretty close to zero and pushing further
in that direction doesn't do much if you
increase it up to about one point five
percent you get enough you get a factor
of two reduction in the damages that's
something that to be expected one thing
we also played with is the notion of
what if vulnerability weren't static as
a percentage of GDP for particular
benchmark but in fact grew over time so
that poor countries as they got richer
and became in per capita terms to
approximate the current developed world
that their vulnerability wouldn't stay
where it was assumed to be but would in
fact as a percentage of damages that
they would see relative to their GDP
shrink to something that looks like the
developed world and doing that letting
the economies grow as they as they will
in the model but simply shrinking the
vulnerabilities to some degree allowed
for a factor of two reduction fifty
percent or so reduction in the damages
the review though in terms of this near
term policy discussion I think provides
enough information to make an economic
case for immediate action without
relying on on all of this argument and
trying to sort through the argument I
think that as Sir Nicholas has suggested
you can identify risks pick something
that you think is dangerous translate
that into a temperature target and then
examine the effects of mitigation
concentration thresholds targets on the
likelihood of crossing those particular
temperature thresholds of dangerous this
is my favorite picture in the whole
review this summarizes just about
everything that you could think of in
the red arrows there's a list of
possible events that you might think is
dangerous in the temperature triggers if
you then say well I agree with the EU
two degrees is a good target that mean
that 550 parts per million would still
leave you a seventy or eighty percent
chance of going over that 400 parts per
million would still leave you with a
thirty percent chance you thought three
degrees was a better target a 550 parts
per million would make that a coin toss
400 parts per million would make it up
in the fourth percent tail I think
that's the sort of calculation and
things that you can think about and once
you have a concentration target in mind
then simple economics of the hotelling
rule applies to first approximation a
concentration target is a cumulative
emissions constraint so it becomes an
exhaustible resource problem he set a
scarcity rent let it go up at the rate
of interest and that's how you minimize
the cost or maximize the value of that
particular resource so we know what to
do the short-term response might
acknowledge the climate risk in the
context of a long-term problem but needs
to think about the political
tractability in the near term and from
people that I've talked to thirty
dollars a ton of co2 or hundred dollars
a ton of carbon seems like sort of a
magic number it's a number where
electricity power plants might switch
from coal to natural gas it's a number
where carbon sequestration might become
economic and it strikes me that in 2007
the price of carbon doesn't have to be
at thirty dollars a ton it's going to go
up at the rate of interest in a
predictable and persistent way what you
need to do is arrange it so the present
value calculations of the private sector
investors using private sector discount
rates interest rates and so no longer
subject to all of the controversy about
what to do for two or three hundred
years we'll find it in their best
interest to make the less
carbon-intensive decisions so also the
notion would be that if you started a
little bit lower if you look at cinnamon
senator Bingaman 'he's bill and started
at seven dollars a ton of co2 instead of
say at fifteen dollars a ton of co2 it
reduces political opposition and it
factors in the likelihood that the
adjustment to the long
term perspective would be a ratcheting
up in 20 20 20 25 investors are smart
they'll see that coming they'll factor
that into the calculations themselves I
think that the notion the fundamental
notion is to try to figure out ways to
avoid enormous locked in investments
that would commit economies of the world
to high carbon intensity means of
production and transportation for
decades 40 50 60 years at a time and
also to create incentives to sort of be
the first mover you know Gore's movie
did stop short of saying anything about
costs he said it was an opportunity the
opportunity is in a persistent
predictive a policy environment to get
there first and make some money out of
it on adaptation I think there's one
critical point to be made in summary
adaptation to climate will be required
even if we shut down emissions tomorrow
of all greenhouse gases we would be
committed to almost another half a
degree of warming over the next fifty to
a hundred years but human systems will
adapt to climate policy as well as adapt
to climate change so that if the notion
is that we have overestimated damages
because we have underestimated the
ability of communities and systems to
adapt then parallel reasoning suggests
that we may have overestimated the cost
of mitigation because we've
underestimated the ability assistance to
adapt to the policy I want to thank Sir
Nicholas and his team for having the
courage to take on this enormous
challenge and for coming here and
continuing the debate for teaching me so
much about all of this and thank Yale
for letting me to continue to
participate in these discussions
what is it called Mendel's hit the down
well I want to thank Sir stern for
coming I recognize that this whole
report process was under tremendous
political constraints and he was given a
thankless task to try to come up with
this and to come with it very quickly
and I guess what in some sense what's
going on here is he's finally getting
that peer review after the fact which is
that unfortunately it perhaps an
unpleasant experience because it's very
little you can do about it after the
fact and it's also unpleasant to have it
happen in public so you can all watch
what it looks like my personal feeling
is that the report is makes a lot of
things in the right direction but it's
not finished and I kind of was hoping
that there could be a stern report to
that would tidy up some things so when
you listen this morning I was guess it
was very impressive God just talked this
morning I was awestruck sort of felt
like i was visiting the Wizard of Oz and
getting a very awe-inspiring
conversation that that I sort of
whimpered away from but unfortunately my
job today is to be toto so the question
is is it in fact the Wizard of Oz or is
is it nothing much there so one of the
things that I guess I want to point out
is that an economic analysis of climate
change is trying to basically minimize
the cost and damages associated with
trying to control it that's the whole
point of an economic analysis
unfortunately the stern report does not
actually do that what the storm report
is actually doing is this looking at the
damage of doing nothing at all against
the cost of abatement of doing a 550
parts per million stabilization target
and it's saying well gee that that
proves that the 550 parts per million
stabilization target is great because
it's better than doing nothing at all
but frankly if we were talking about a
different topic we're talking about
education policy and I said I've got a
great education policy and look it's
better than closing all the schools you
wouldn't be terribly convinced if I were
I said wow I've got a great health care
policy this is my favorite health care
policy and my proof that it's the best
one is it's better than having no
doctors no prescriptions no health care
at all it's it turns out it's not a
convincing argument to compare having
one policy against having no policy at
all what you must do is compare having
one policy against having other policies
which are also perfectly plausible
alternatives and that's something that
the stern report doesn't do it doesn't
do it for the 450 parts per million that
my team would prefer to have and it
doesn't do it for the 650 or the 7 50
parts per million that it actually is
more than norm for the literature on on
the economic analysis of climate change
so this is before you get all involved
in the details of this this is actually
just a report that's not doing what it
ought to be doing if it was to be an
economic analysis so what the things
what are some of the things that it
ought to be doing well it ought to be
making consistent assumptions between
cost and damages it looked to me like
there is a 18 of people that stay the
costs another team that studied the
damages they didn't always talk to each
other then it makes the similar
assumptions about little details like
discount rates GDP growth population
growth energy growth so this is just a
little detail it's one of the beauties
of having a model is you do use the same
assumptions when you're looking at the
cost in the damages and it's so it's
something that's difficult to manage
when you've got a big project like this
and you don't have something to to keep
yourself being consistent and what the
most important thing is that the report
has got to evaluate alternative
stabilization targets that it's got to
reevaluate targets which which fall
everywhere from 452 850 on perhaps 950
realistic targets that do involve making
abatement activities they're all
involving bateman activities but they
range from doing very strong abatement
actions to doing what's much more
moderate
and this is kind of very important
because one of the most important things
that this reports trying to say is that
we ought to be doing things strong and
fast and hard today when virtually all
the economic analysis says we should be
doing things today the u.s. current US
policy is not appropriate doing nothing
is not what any economist here would
actually recommend on this panel but
what it is does say we should start
moderately and get much more strenuous
over time so in this regard I kind of I
strongly support the insights the
professor Nordhaus was sharing with you
earlier that that it's it's true that we
want to do abatement but do we want to
do it right now or do we want to do
strong abatement in the future and start
with a much more moderate policy so the
literature currently suggests that we
should start moderately and get tougher
in the future now how could you get this
different result that we should actually
be doing something right now well let's
go on you'd have to make some kinds of
statements about why having a lower
stabilization target is in fact a better
idea so one of things it's true about
stabilization targets is that that was
pointed out earlier is the lower the
stabilization target the more emissions
we bateman has to be done right away and
so if you pick a higher stabilization
target one of the things that allows you
to do is it allows you to do a little
bit of abatement today and then a lot
more in the future it gives you more
time to choose your bateman path so
here's some examples of different
abatement paths if this isn't these
aren't exactly precise they're trying to
get a qualitative idea across and that
is that if you're going to do with my 50
parts per million abatement strategy the
idea is that you're going to deviate
from a business-as-usual strategy quite
early and you're going to have to do
abatement immediately and and there's
there's that's a result of their
analysis but if you start to look at
higher and higher stabilization pass it
turns out that you can be closer and
closer to business as usual in the near
term it's just in the future you have to
deviate from from business as usual so
the level of the stables
path is very important in terms of
determining how early do you have to
have to actually act so one of the
questions is then why do we need 550 and
not 750 well if we looked at that
earlier argument the economic literature
is kind of saying well you don't really
want 550 if you look at 550 the cost of
abatement because it turns out it's very
difficult to actually abate carbon the
cost of abatement exceeded the benefits
and so economist before thought a 550
path was a little too aggressive and so
they were arguing for something higher
stabilization rate than that at 650 or
750 but in this report they're arguing
for a 550 and so one of the things you
might want to think about as well what
are all the assumptions that this report
does that weren't made done before that
lead them to this conclusion so one of
the things that that I personally have
studied a great deal is this question
about what about damages well one of the
things that the report assumes is that
market damages will be five percent of
GDP now when we think of five percent of
GDP we're often thinking about today's
GDP but what they're thinking about is
actually the GDP and 2200 so they're
talking about market damages normal
market damages which are around 60
trillion dollars a year now why is that
remarkable because if we actually look
at the micro studies that we tried to do
of the sensitivity of market damages
that's numbers probably closer to 600
billion that is it's one one-hundredth
of that number so 60 trillion is a huge
number to assume they're also thinking
that non-market damages are going to be
60 trillion dollars a year every year
that's a huge number at the moment we're
having trouble identifying non-market
damages that exist so that trying to put
a number of 60 trillion dollars on the
kinds of things that are even possible
right the moment we have no way to get
to that kind of a number severe storm
damages things like hurricanes again the
report assumes there'll be 60 trillion
dollars every year now it reports a
little cavalier about throwing out these
big numbers because when you when you
say it in terms of five percent of GDP
that sounds like well that's doesn't
sound too much
but when you argue about these things in
terms of the absolute dollar amount of
them these are enormous effects and as
far as we can tell to date we just
cannot do this we don't with there's
just no scenarios where we can arrive at
damage estimates or anywhere close to
this much money what else does it assume
well one of these you've also heard
about a great deal is it as soon as
these very low discount rates and one of
the professor crime mentioned or dr.
Klein mentioned is that it's not just
that the discount rates are low you know
it's also assuming that the interest
rates are low that is one of these he
mentioned is you could spend fifty
dollars today and you'd have a million
dollars to spend if you just invested
that at the market interest rate well
that intuition is one of the reasons why
delaying abatement is makes sense why
why pushing debate bateman off makes
sense is because we can invest abatement
dollars in the market and straight and
earn that much more in the future no
matter what we think the discount rate
should be it turns out that we can
invest in savings that we're going to
eventually spend on abatement and get
the market interest rate so it turns out
that's all in a push us away from doing
dramatic things today and wanting to do
more dramatic things into the future
another thing that this report assumes
is that there's going to be a dramatic
change in technical change that's going
to occur in that the whole field of
trying to reduce the carbon emissions
there's they're going to assume that the
costs of abatement fall three percent
every year and that's a very dramatic
rate of technical change if we look at
one of our more successful fields of
technical change things like agriculture
that only grows at two percent a year so
this is going to have to grow at a much
faster rate and that's an assumption
that's implicit in in this argument this
is going to be cheap because if it turns
out that's not the case this is going to
be much more expensive another thing
that the report assumes is that there's
going to be no effect on the value of
fossils of the existing fossil fuels and
one of the reasons we can get away with
that is if it assumes that in fact we
can put it we can get get carbon storage
and still
burn all the coal and oil that we've got
at hand but if it turns out that we
can't actually extract carbon from the
atmosphere and store it in the ground
then in order to cut carbon emissions
we're basically not going to burn coal
we're going to leave it in the ground
and that's kind of an enormous effect on
the value of the stocks of fossil fuels
that's a cost that's not counted in this
report the report assumes when it looks
at the costs how much it's going to cost
us worldwide that we're going to have an
efficient allocation of abatement and
that means that the entire globe has got
to participate in this abatement project
and do it efficiently so at the
efficiency of a global program is going
to be very important to keeping the cost
low if we don't do it efficiently it's
going to be very expensive and finally
the report assumes that deforestation is
going to be cheap to control the fact
despite the fact that deforestation is
occurring globally and it's largely in
the hands of lots of local people that
are very difficult to control it might
very well be that deforestation issues
are going to actually turn out to be a
lot more expensive than we think and
then finally there's a bunch of
environmental assumptions that are kind
of hidden in the report because the
report doesn't go into the great deal
about detail about them but if you look
at some of the papers that are behind
the report as to what kind of mitigation
can we do to actually reduce carbon well
if they have very large environmental
impacts or at least they might one thing
that we've said we will do is bring in a
lot of renewable crops well it turns out
they're assuming that they're going to
have 500 million hectares of renewable
crops that's a huge fraction of the
amount of arable land in unit in the
world so that's going to have a dramatic
effect on the whole on agriculture and
feeding people so this is an example of
an abatement program that actually might
cause dramatic hunger so what else is
there they're assuming they'll be a
doubling of nuclear power plants there's
a question well is that going to be
something that that for example America
will be really excited about we haven't
built a nuclear power plant in I think
25 years would you be excited about to
note that this report assumes we'll have
twice as many as we have now
what else do we are just the report
assume as soon as that we're going to
have to damn a lot more rivers basically
than the remaining free-flowing rivers
that too has environmental impacts it
assumes that we're not going to have
problems storing carbon that we're going
to take carbon out of smokestacks and
store them if it turns out that those
programs fail that's a whole bunch of
new sources of carbon to cause new
disasters in the future so this is an
abatement program that has a potentially
disastrous environmental consequence for
the very reasons that the abatement
program exists and then finally it says
well let's just locate two million
windmills obviously we've seen a
windmill here and we mill there I've
been delighted to see those windmills
all through Europe but two million
windmills is a lot of windmills and one
of these that you might have recognized
it's just trying to locate 11 windmill 1
windmill farm along the coast in this
region caused enormous fewer well one
windmill farm is going to be nothing
compared to the number of windmill farms
we're going to need to provide the kind
of energy that we currently get from
fossil fuels so one of these you have to
recognize is that fossil fuels are bad
and I totally agree with that aspect and
they're bad in more than just the fact
that they release carbon but one of
these you also have to recognize is that
some of the alternatives that were
considering to replace the fossil fuels
also have serious problems so in
conclusion I was hoping that I could
encourage the sturm report to finish
that is to go back and look at six-fifty
look at seven fifty parts per million
actually do a careful analysis of why
550 is better than 650 given their
assumptions come back justify why they
think this five percent of GDP is just a
good ideas as a reasonable estimate of
what kind of damages we actually were
going to get and then do a better job of
explaining the difference between
moderate abatement and dramatic
near-term abatement because that's
really where the policy issue is that
the idea that we're not going to do any
abatement I think is going to be an
issue that's going to disappear in a
couple years when we have a change in
there will be a Bateman but the question
is whether we need dramatic near-term
strong abatement with very high costs or
whether we should start with moderate
abatement that's the place where the
debate needs to go thank you taking
thanks to both them to Gary and Rob the
comments the lot of what Gary said was I
think looking at what we've done
expressing it in a somewhat different
way but in the same kind of spirit that
we offered the so let me just pick up on
a couple of a couple of points there and
again I think Gary like Rob ignored the
basic sensitivity analysis that we've
applied in in the review I mean if you
don't like eater equals 1 and delta
equals naught point 1 increase eater 1.5
or so you get the kinds of rates of
return that you think you see as social
rates of return in the market and you
cut off the bet the but you know that
you cut off the weights of the benefit
at the far end that you don't like with
each r equals 1 and you still get the
basic conclusions that we got in terms
of the damages saved being substantially
greater than the one percent it costs to
save them so I'm a little bit puzzled
with the sort of fixation on that that
formulation when you can change it a
little bit and you still get the basic
result of the comparison to the costs
and the damages with the one being much
smaller than the other on comparing GDP
and consumption there it seems to me I
don't think that there's such a big
problem because when we looked at the
cost side the costs in terms of one
percent of GDP that's just to like a
price index it's like a one-off one
percent increase in a price index and
that's a price index it would apply to
consumption and to GDP if you're looking
at wrong run steady States then there's
no difference in percentage changes
between the two things so I don't have
any problem there in applying percentage
changes either one to the other if
you're looking at long run and roughly
balanced growth eventually so there
doesn't seem to me to be a problem there
the now and forever language wasn't
particularly felicitous and in
reflection we might have used some other
language but the point is that it's a
balanced growth equivalent you know
you're looking at something which is
growing at a constant rate and you're
shoving it out for your shoving it down
and that's what that means and i find
that actually having more or less
intuitive calibration for something as
complicated and expected utility
integral is actually helpful and you're
going to need something like that if
you're going to put if you're going to
compare it with the percentage of costs
so I think the balanced growth equipment
was quite useful tool for comparing
percentage damages saved and percentage
costs moving now to to rob i'm thinking
unfinished business it certainly is this
would never be any pretense at having
the last word how could there be and
that's not where we where we tried to be
and one or two people have mentioned the
political constraints which i find these
may have been uncomfortable in the sense
that i and the team didn't know what the
conclusions would be before we started
neither did Gordon Brown when he asked
me to do it certainly I found out what I
was going to think along the way the
Chancellor read it towards the end and
had a think and that was the process I
didn't feel under any political
constraints I had a home to go to the
London School of Economics where I am
now going to go I could have gone
halfway through last year if I'd wanted
to be when fine with me so
sound like rather good idea at times for
the point is I didn't feel under any
particular pressures those are you from
outside who think you know what sort of
political pressures I was under I i
puzzled how you work that out he knew
something I didn't know so you know
whilst you are operating in a political
environment I made the point about peer
review and there's a limit to how much
you can sort of share around because of
the way and the argument gets starts to
take place in the newspapers rather than
the academic profession that's a
constraint but it's not a constraint on
what you actually say at the end so I
didn't feel that political constraint i
certainly felt a time constraint that
was very painful and i would like to
have taken the analysis forward now what
about comparing schools with no schools
and that sort of thing i honestly don't
think that that's what we did and
trouble of writing 700 pages is people
don't always read it all and if you and
that's our fault I apologize for that
but we do in chapter 13 have a fairly
detailed discussion of the way in which
these kinds of calculations of damages
have to be put together and the argument
that we were making was a strategic
argument using the model which was
similar to the strategic argument I
started off with that when we're talking
about stabilization levels we should be
thinking of something at or below 550
parts per million we ran that in terms
of risk and we ran that in terms of the
model so it's not saying 550 or nothing
it's saying here are very good arguments
for coming below 550 where below 550 we
don't know we heard the discussion this
morning that 550 is outrageously high
that's one point of view we need to have
that discussion 450 is probably very
very hard to do so somewhere between 450
and 550 so we used both the intuitive
risk reduction approach and the modeling
approach to say we should we be below
550 and we left open we're below 5 15 as
we heard this morning
that is a really important discussion to
have if you really think we should wait
and see and invest their money in nice
high rate of return projects I give the
same answer like a really a few minutes
ago to to Bill I mean you're taking
yourself into difficult territory in my
view you'd be running up against a price
of environment relative to other goods
which is going up very quickly and that
rate of return in terms of what it buys
for environment reduction would not be
high enough to offset the rising price
in environmental goods so you going to
be very careful to treat this as
specifically the many good model it is
and not to ramp it down to one good
model or reduce it to one good model
just by assuming effectively constant
prices on the cheapness of mitigation
that is an area where it does seem to me
we have to look much more closely I'd
simply remarked that the International
Energy Agency a month or so after we
published a report crawled all over the
technological options in actually rather
greater detail and we were able to do
and came out with numbers which are
similar or below the numbers that we
came up with and that was reassuring in
terms of our estimates and Rob said
several times the report assumes this
report assumes that about these
different technologies what we did is
gave of gave an example of the kinds of
portfolios that might yield these kinds
of cost reduction that was one method we
use the second method we used to
estimate costs was one which essentially
terry barker did it for us he surveyed
all the various cost estimates in the
literature and he came up with something
around one percent and there are a lot
of estimates out there so we did it two
ways we did it with little bare hands
looking at technological possibilities
and then it's Anderson led us on that
professor of energy policy Imperial
College and it is true that you have to
think through what the alternatives
might be but we gave examples of what
the alternatives might be we emphasize
very strongly that the portfolio should
turn out to be whatever the port
turns out to be on a good on a strong
price of carbon and on strong
investments in R&D and I would be very
happy to see pilots and much greater
research on deforestation I suspect that
the costs of deforestation will look
quite small in some parts of the world
and quite high in other parts of the
world and it's a research issue to try
to identify where it may be low where it
might be high I think it might be quite
low in Africa and Latin America quite
high in some parts of Asia but that's
something that further research should
have a look at I suspect that there's a
lot out there to some time that's quite
cheap price might go up as time goes
time goes by finally on the consistency
of the costs and the damage assumptions
we've poured all over that one and we
did put a paper up on the web on Monday
I know 700 pages of report already and
then putting more papers up on the web
isn't terribly friendly but we did try
to look in detail at that suggestion
that there was some kind of
inconsistency between those two things
not surprisingly found that there wasn't
but if you like to have a look at that
you can see how we try to deal with it
obviously it's much too detailed in the
minutes that I've got here and finally
on dramatic again Rob used dramatic and
bill used dramatic it all depends
dramatic in what space I think it gets
more dramatic the later you leave it if
you start now and spread your action out
over time it's less drama than if you
wait and get yourself in a difficult
situation from which it's very difficult
to extricate and I think to wait and see
and Potter on up to 650 would actually
be a very difficult situation to be and
it's then that action would start to get
dramatic it's much less dramatic if you
start now and do it in a measured way
with a
target like 550 in mind